So there is no real correct answer to this quiz if
you really don't like money, I guess you could prefer not
to be paid at all. The closest thing to a correct
answer is that it depends, and it depends on how you
interpret the meaning of biweekly. We could look that up in
the dictionary to decide how we should interpret it, and if
we look up biweekly in the dictionary, what we see is
the definition of biweekly, which is right here. It says happening
every two weeks is the first definition. The
second definition is happening twice a week. If you
have the first definition, you'd rather be paid
weekly, assuming you'd like more money. If you have
the second definition, you'd rather be paid biweekly.
Maybe that's the problem with paper dictionaries, that they're
not very precise, because they're old things. Let's look
up a more modern dictionary, let's see what Wiktionary
has to say about this. So, here's the Wiktionary entry for
biweekly, and if we scroll down, we can see that it has two
meanings. Occurring once every two weeks, occurring twice a week,
this is chiefly in the UK the American
dictionary didn't seem to think that. It seemed to
think both definitions occurred in both countries. So,
this is a pretty big problem. If we wrote
a computer program and the program was doing our payroll
and had to decide what it meant to pay someone biweekly,
we want to make sure it understood that the same
way the programmer did. So that's one important reason why we
need to invent new languages like Python to program computers,
rather than using natural languages that we already understand. And that's
because we don't really understand languages like English or Mandarin, that
there's lots of things that different people will understand different ways.
And this happens at the granularity of words like biweekly.
It also happens in complete sentences where there are many different
ways to interpret the same phrase. Another reason we don't use
natural languages for programming is that natural languages are actually very
verbose. To write a program, we need to describe exactly
what the computer should do in very precise sequence of steps.
If we had to describe all those details using a natural
language, that would require a huge amount of text. So we'll
see soon that with a programming language like Python,
we only need a few lines of code to
describe a complicated thing and describe it in a
very precise, step by step way. So I want
you to think about as we write programs in
this class, how much more detail you need to
actually describe in English, precisely how to do what
we're describing with a few lines of Python code.